this movie because it's based on a true
story and is dealing with real people
there was a lot of pressure to present
these Granite Mountain hotshots in the
most accurate and kind of honorable way
I met with a lot of the families of guys
that were on the crew it was my goal to
try to capture as much of this film in
camera as possible most of the fire in
the film was captured for real so the
actors had some really close encounters
with large fire and got a sense of what
it was like to be a wildland firefighter
if you give me a chance I won't let you
down there are scenes in the film where
we're dealing with such large fire we
needed to use visual effects and they
did some of the most complex visual
effects work I think they've ever done
to simulate the chaos of a raging
wildfire a wildfire burning at night
does create imagery that you haven't
seen before and a feeling of almost
being in another place or another planet
my new fire was something that's really
gonna push camera so we did a lot of
testing to try to get the right approach
the standard format of the film is 2.4
to 1 it's a very wide aspect ratio for
IMAX
I wanted to do something special because
this screen is so large and the audience
is so close to it we finished a special
version of the film that is 1.9 to 1 and
you see the movie in IMAX you're going
to see it in a format that has more
image at the top and bottom of the
screen
fills your peripheral vision and I think
it does create a more immersive
experience I think it's important to
create a special experience in theaters
IMAX has always been a special way to
see a movie and I think it will continue
to be that way
[Music]